this week in the valley community has
come together to help in the search for
a missing two-year-old boy
amari nicholson has been missing since
wednesday may 5th he was last seen near
paradise and twain
reporter kate houston joins us live from
that area tonight with the latest on the
search for amari
kate yes sasha well a handful of
volunteers
canvassed businesses and homes in this
area trying to find
any information on amari's whereabouts
they also passed out about
a thousand of these flyers in the hopes
that these efforts will bring amari back
home
now for the past few days the search
focused on the area immediately
surrounding emerald suites on paradise
and twain
where he was last seen today volunteers
with nevada child seekers
broadened their search to include other
major streets and businesses
the group says it's important to keep
the search going saying many people who
work down in this area don't necessarily
live here
so they can spread the word in their own
neighborhoods and online
from there you know the miracles happen
people are gonna be able to send in a
tip and maybe they've seen him or maybe
they have information
we search no matter what and 24 hours a
day so we're never going to stop
searching or being a voice for him
margarita edwards helped coordinate this
search party nevada child seekers is now
getting some support from
other organizations in the state
including members of search and rescue
from
project desert angels in parum even a
toddler can cover a lot of ground in a
short period of time and if somebody
lured him away then it takes that one
person that saw a vehicle
or if somebody's seen a vehicle that
they haven't seen before that's also a
huge
a huge tip to law enforcement
nevada child seekers plans to continue
their canvassing efforts to help
find amari this weekend amari's father
drove down from reno to get involved
with the search
more of his family is now flying into
town to help
as well now back out here live the
family is offering a 30
thousand dollar reward for amari's safe
return home
metro police are investigating this case
they're also asking
anybody with information to reach out to
them reporting live from paradise and
twain kate houston 8 news now